in one of our last interviews with Aaron
Carter he spoke super highly of you and
said you were one of his Muses did you
know that and what will you always
remember about him
Aaron was such an immense life such an
immense light in our lives and I just
wish all the love I possibly can to his
friends and family right now
Riverdale I can't believe it's coming to
a close have you begun to process are
you okay
um well I'm currently on episode 4 of
season seven shooting it's uh I haven't
begun the process honestly it feels like
I've been doing this for so long that
I'm just like yep another season I'll be
back next year and then when it's over
it's gonna hit me and it's gonna be
really emotional I'm excited I think
it's gonna be nice to have more time to
do other projects and to explore other
characters and dive in deeper to new
experiences at the same time I
absolutely love our career we've had the
same group for seven years which is
insane and the same cast for seven years
so that I'm going to miss
terribly yeah Cheryl's done some some
truly wild things throughout the series
but is there one thing you really want
her to do before the series ends I
really wanted her to write a broomstick
but it seems as if those days are not
gonna happen
a little bit about that I really wanted
to be put on wires on a broomstick I
don't know why
it's like my Halloween dreams come true
the uh blonde brunette redhead Tick Tock
account
[Music]
does it continue
we've been discussing I mean we're going
to continue hanging out so I think it'll
continue as well yeah it'll be different
but we'll figure it out recently uh
Cheryl got like those Phoenix Powers it
gave me a little bit of Scarlet Witch
Vibes you've been fantas Mary Jane
poison ivy all kinds of characters in
recent years is any of that world of
interest to you is there a character you
would love to play in like the MCU or DC
or something like that
I haven't given it much thought because
I don't think there's much you just
never know what's going to come your way
I live my life more like whatever comes
into my inbox like I'll read and then
we'll kind of fight for it if I love it
I'm not gonna sit here and Fan cast
myself but I would love to join the MCU
I'd love those movies I think they're
really fun and it's very
um rule bending so that would be
wonderful if it ever happened
my dream is to own a hotel
a new one where everything isn't falling
apart
I know you could do a lot better than
this old hotel of ours I love this old
hotel of ours it's not always the place
that's important it's the people I want
to ask about minimum because I
absolutely love him what was it like
working with him we've known each other
for a while actually we met doing an
interview for Lilly Singh a couple years
ago and just connected because we're
both vegan and we just really got along
and then when this opportunity came
about we both jumped on it just because
we really wanted to work together and
he's so lovely and so collaborative and
just as Charming as you imagine if not
more I have to say your customer service
skills in this movie are incredible have
you had a customer service job before
um I've had like a hundred
what was your biggest one not an
understatement my biggest or my Maybe
my biggest one I have two I can think of
I was a hostess at a very bougie
Hollywood restaurant and got screamed at
by every big agent in town because they
couldn't get a reservation and I also
worked as a waitress at a hookah lounge
which is off-brand but um that was
unique and I actually used to I used to
play games with myself where I would see
if I could memorize people's orders
without writing it down and then they'd
be like you need to write this down and
I probably should but didn't
wasn't always wrong
I mean I memorized things for a living
right so it's true it was pretty I was
pretty good I made a couple mistakes
here and there but like for the most
part there's a reason I don't do it now
I don't think I was that great is
Christmas your favorite holiday or if
not what is
I have a tie it's Halloween and
Christmas to me
well two hard hits
you got I mean the trio killed Halloween
God
oh
yeah that's the part of Halloween that
we love and then Lily and I will go and
do every haunted house we could possibly
find Cami could not be bothered to join
that to completely 180 from the warm hug
of Christmas to horror The Strangers was
a movie that scared me more than any
other horror movie in the world because
I felt like it was like the main
characters did everything they could and
still like couldn't
horrifying
tell me about this remake there's three
movies like I I need to know about it
so we shot all three already
actually done in the cans and it is just
it's more bone chilling than the
original because what we really wanted
to do with these three was make it so
that people along the ride were thinking
the exact same thing you thought she has
done everything she can to escape these
people and yet they're still here that's
the scariest part of that film and it is
that times a thousand I think there's a
little bit more of a back story to why
it's happening too which I think people
really like especially OG fans and it's
a wild ride it is a wild ride and by the
end I hope that you are just absolutely
rooting for Maya is it is it a remake
like same characters or is this like a
new It's A New Concept but it's a kind
of a remake of the original and then
there's two additional to continue the
story because at the end of the first
one originally
you see that live Tyler's character
might be alive
continuously continuing the story
through two and three of what could have
happened after one was over but it's a
different character so it's myself and
my boyfriend are driving to
um an undisclosed location and they
can't make it there that's something all
I literally love just yeah
[Music]